تأكيد الهبوط
[تصفيق]
بعد ثلاث سنوات من هبوط مركبة ناسا الفضائية
على
سطح المريخ ، فقد قدمت المعلومات التي
تم إرسالها لجمعها من ملايين
الأميال ،
وهذه هي بالتأكيد البيانات التي
كنا ننتظرها
لعقود من الزمن لأول مرة.
رسموا خريطة للجزء الداخلي من كوكب صخري آخر
اكتشفوا قشرة أرق من المتوقع
والمفاجأة الأكبر هي أن نواة أخف وزنا وأكثر سائلًا
من التقديرات السابقة للمقارنة ،
فإن قلب الأرض أكثر كثافة مما يعني
أن قلب المريخ
مكون جزئيًا على الأقل من
عناصر
مختلفة.  هذا مهم لماذا يجب أن
يهتم أبناء الأرض
بتكوين المريخ ، فهو يسمح
لنا
بأخذ نظرياتنا عن تكوين
الكواكب الصخرية بشكل عام
والأرض بشكل خاص
وفهم كيف
تشكل كوكبنا من
السديم الشمسي الأولي
كيف تغير من مجرد نوع من  كرة
من مادة نيزكية رمادية لا يمكن تمييزها
عن الكوكب المتنوع
الذي لدينا اليوم
المحيطات والقارات
[تصفيق]
هناك زلازل على سطح المريخ ، ولكن على سطح
المريخ
يطلق عليها marsquakes ، أمضت المسبار البصري
مقياس الزلازل المتطور
عامين في قياسها
وتتبع تلك الموجات الزلزالية
أثناء تموجاتها عبر الكوكب الأحمر
بينما يركز الروبوت النشط الآخر التابع لناسا
على  السطح من
المتوقع أن تجمع المركبة الجوالة المثابرة أول صخرة مريخية لها في
أي يوم الآن ،
ولكن لأول مرة في التاريخ
أصبحت شركة ناسا
في مايو ثاني
دولة في
العالم تهبط بنجاح على متن مركبة فضائية على المريخ ،
شهد بيل نيلسون
على ذلك.  الكونغرس أن الصور التي تم بثها
من العربة الجوالة جو رونغ
يجب أن تكون دعوة للاستيقاظ ، ندرك فجأة
أننا لا نملك كل هذا
وأنه منافس عدواني للغاية
كريستين فيشر سي إن واشنطن